[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
So the next speaker
is Cliff Kuang.
Cliff is author of an upcoming
book titled "User Friendly"
around--
kind of like a
retrospective on the role
of interaction designers.
He was head of product at Fast
Company, author and editor
of thousands of articles around
design and direction design.
And yeah, thank you.
CLIFF KUANG: Thanks.
Hopefully this is working OK.
So yeah, thank you
for the introduction.
As mentioned, I
used to be the head
of product at Fast Company.
Before that I was the founder
of a site that some of you guys
may know called
Fast Company Design.
And for the last
five years, I've
been working on a book about
the history of the idea of user
friendliness.
Where that's taken me in
the last year is thinking--
I think more and more deeply
about how interaction design
relates to AI and how it relates
to anticipatory interfaces
that we're seeing more
and more of today.
So I'll just start by rolling
the tape back a little bit.
In the beginning there
was interaction design.
We focus on making things
predictable, right?
This has been the mode
of the last 40 years
or so of interaction
design, which
is like making a screen
that doesn't have to change,
even if the software
can be updated, right?
These things are fairly
static, predictable.
They work off of
cognitive principles
that relate to the
most basic ways
that we actually
process information.
But I think in the last four
or five years, a lot of you,
if you're UX-trained,
you probably
went to school in
an era in which
things like modeling,
things like consistency,
things like affordances
were drilled into your head.
They were beaten into your mind.
I personally never
thought that I'd
see the day when a lot of those
things started to disappear,
and yet they are, right?
So right now, if you look at
a mobile game, for example,
there are no affordances
on that screen.
There is the assumption that you
discover what that interface is
and how it works, right,
but it's not necessarily
laid out for you in a way
that classical interaction
design would have done so.
Conversational interfaces,
another layer of complexity
in which the affordances,
the basic affordances
are not there anymore.
And the mental model
of what that thing does
is no longer stable,
right, because it's
changing all the time,
because its capabilities are
being augmented and
updated by the cloud,
and because a lot of the
modeling itself is changing.
So the point is
that affordances,
where they used to
live in the interface,
now increasingly
live in our head.
They are the assumptions you
make about how things work.
They are the expectations you
bring to what a computer should
be able to do.
And therefore, the surface
of design is changing now.
And so I would say design now
lives in our expectations,
our assumptions, our biases
about interfaces, right?
And that in turn is the
new material of design.
What we're talking about
is less expectations
about how things perform,
let's say, physically,
where you might have talked
about the animation metaphors
that underlie an interface.
We're talking much more about
vaguer notions about what
people aspire to, what
they assume something will
be able to do, and things
that are much harder to map
these days.
And so around that insight,
I wanted to introduce you--
I'm sorry, hopefully the
resolution is showing up.
But what I wanted
to introduce you to
is a simple framework
for thinking
about how to design for
assistive AI systems
that I think--
and the reason I thought
about this framework is
that I think we're
mashing together
a lot of different
ways AI can help us
and a lot of different
ways that AI can
work as an interface right now.
And what this is
showing is there's
this sphere of human conception,
this sphere of how humans view
themselves and what
they can do, and there
is a sphere of human
capability, which
is the things that
they're good at
and the things that
they're capable of doing.
These things don't
overlap, right?
As we all know, looking at users
and looking at what users do,
humans often overestimate
what they can do
and sometimes they
underestimate as well.
Sometimes these things overlap,
but they're not necessarily
perfect overlaps.
So what I want to talk about
is basically each section
of this Venn diagram.
So let's talk about
one, problem one.
I call i t the meh problem.
And this relates to the leftmost
section on this Venn diagram,
right?
This is where human capability
exceeds human self-conception
about what you do.
So this is a section where
we're basically talking about--
well, actually, I
think I switched this.
Yes, this is human
capability exceeding
human self-conception.
These are the things that you
take for granted every day.
These are things you don't
assume, that you don't even
think about because
they're so embedded
in your typical way
of doing things.
And this is actually the work--
I'm not going to talk a
ton about this sphere,
because this is
what we familiarly
know is the work of AI
and AI design right now.
This is offloading the work
that we would rather not
be doing for ourselves, right?
And in this case, actually, some
classical interaction design
principles hold.
Things need to be reliable,
accountable, reversible,
transparent.
I think I would argue right
now that the dialogue is
a little bit frozen right now
on these specific problems.
But as I'll get
to in a second, I
think we're moving
beyond that, and we're
moving to more
complicated problems
relating to those other spheres.
So let's get into problem two.
I call this the duh problem.
This is where human
self-conception actually
exceeds human capability.
These are things where
you think that you're
better than you are actually
are at doing something, right?
And this is something
that has not
been talked about a ton related
to interaction design and AI,
because these are things where
a machine makes a suggestion,
and you're just like, so what?
Like, that was stupid.
Like, I didn't need a
suggestion for that.
But that actually
suggests a different mode
of having to design
for that interaction.
And so we're going to
get into some examples.
These are obviously
augmented capabilities
that we put too much stock in.
Sorry for the lorem.
I thought I cleared that out.
So an example that I would
give you guys is IBM Watson.
IBM Watson has been
a troubled product,
I think, in a lot of ways,
for various different reasons.
But one reason that I
actually want to talk about
is actually less publicized, and
it's a super interesting one.
It specifically relates to
IBM Watson Cancer, which
in some ways is their,
I guess, keystone
product, the one
that they've actually
had the most success in creating
more robust data sets, and have
productized first.
So the way the product
works is basically,
you enter in diagnosis data
if you're an oncologist.
So it's much like a database
interface, pretty simple,
pretty well-trod path
in interaction design.
And then you get
treatment options.
These are presented
in bands for you.
I couldn't present a
screenshot here, unfortunately.
They're presented in bands for
you that are basically related
to confidence levels,
right, the top one
is basically the
most likely course
of treatment and the
most likely diagnosis,
given the information
that you had entered.
I went and actually
watched for a while
a team of UX researchers
watching somebody
use this product in the
wild and being introduced
to it for the first time.
And one of the most interesting
things that I heard,
it was this duh problem, right?
It's like, so the
doctor had gone
through the problem of
entering all this data in,
and it essentially had been
presented with something
that they thought
was no added value.
This was something that
was not that interesting
because the doctor was
like, this is familiar.
And so given this thing
that could actually
scrape tens of thousands
of journal articles
from the best
journals in the world
and collapse that understanding
into three clear, concise
recommendations, right, this
is an incredibly powerful thing
to be doing.
The doctor was like, so what?
Like, so what?
Even though that doctor
could never in their lifetime
read all those journals,
it was presenting them
more information than they could
possibly gather on their own,
but the doctor, when presented
with that information
said, this, you know, being
a doctor is like an art.
This is just the recipe.
I don't need this.
So that's a super
interesting place to be,
in which the doctor
actually doesn't
recognize the power of the
system and the capabilities
it affords.
So it presented this problem,
which went unsaid in the room,
in which--
IBM, I could tell, was super
embarrassed that I saw,
in real time, which
is, why would somebody
ever use something that
was just a help meet?
They wouldn't, right?
[COUGHING]
Excuse me.
Getting over a cold.
So the question is
how do you actually
show that AI is adding value?
So you might think you do things
like progressive disclosure,
evolving interfaces,
discovered capabilities, right?
pretty That would be your
pretty standard strategy, right,
taking somebody along
for the ride, basically.
Showing them your
homework, showing
how you arrived at an answer and
involving them at the arrival
to that answer, right?
But I would say this
uncovers a different problem.
This is a case in which
the interface as designed
was focusing on the rule
rather than the exception.
This is a case where
it may have been
more interesting to reverse the
paradigm of what interaction
design typically does and
instead focus on the exception
So you can imagine an interface
that would have instead only
notified you when something
was out of the ordinary,
when something did not fit your
mental model of how something
should work, right?
And that would be a completely
different type of interface.
And so you might move
from a different scenario.
So instead of going from
entering diagnosis data
to getting treatment
options, you
might instead move from
something that was passively
collecting diagnosis
data and then showing
useful exceptions, right?
But you may have noticed, in
switching this paradigm we now
have a completely different
problem the interaction design
has had up to date, right?
Because it's not about entering
in information actively.
It's about collecting
information passively.
That's an entirely
different problem
that comes with it a
sociological setting,
psychological setting, and
all kinds of different issues
about how you gather information
and how you gather information
passively.
So that the doctor--
because, I guess what I'm--
backing up what I'm saying is
that no doctor would ever go
through the process of sitting
for 30 minutes to enter in data
on the off chance they might
get an exception, right?
So that actually has to
be a passive interface.
And that's a completely
different way
of thinking about how to
build interfaces altogether.
So that's one
problem that comes up
when you deal with that
different part of that Venn
diagram that I showed
you, this question
of how do you
capture information
invisibly in a way
that actually doesn't
put any burden on the user.
Now moving on,
problem three, I think
is probably more familiarly
known as the killer robots
problem, right?
So this is basically
where the human being says
I can do something, and, in
fact, their capability lines
up with the fact that
they can do something.
And so they think, like,
I'm going to be replaced.
I'm going to be threatened
by this interface.
This is doing something
that I should do myself
but it's not letting me do.
And this is a different
problem entirely as well.
So this relates
to helping us when
we don't know that we
need it, right, this
relates to interfaces that
are trying to help you
when you think that
you've solved a problem
but you may not have.
And so I want to give you an
example of an interface that
was developed and
still being developed
at Carnegie Mellon
by a group there
that's actually looked at how
do you develop a interface that
would help doctors make
decisions about when
to insert an artificial heart.
And what's interesting, when
you talk about decision systems
for doctors is that we see
all this kind of promise,
we see all this kind of hype
being told about what AI can do
and the concept in helping
doctors make decisions.
The thing that
belies this there's
probably about 30 years of
academic research showing
that every single
decision-assistive system
for doctors has failed.
They fail all the time.
We do not know how to build
these interfaces at all.
We still don't know
how do you get a doctor
to accept a recommendation
or assistance from a machine.
And part of that
is physical, right?
It's very hard to actually have
log-in systems in hospitals
in which not just one person
accesses a piece of data.
That's an entirely
hard UX problem.
There's physical problems
relating to doctors
just can't use touch screens.
But putting those aside,
there's actually something
deeper at work here.
When that team at
Carnegie Mellon
actually looked
at heart surgeons
and why they might not
use such interfaces,
the things that we uncovered
was this had to do with ego,
it had to do with
hierarchy, and it
had to do with self-perception.
So doctors by their nature
thought I am the exception.
Nobody is going to
tell me because I'm
a high performer that does not
need to be told the basics.
So automatically a huge hill to
climb if you are an interaction
designer.
The second thing was hierarchy.
Doctors often, they work
in very regimented places,
where if you're a nurse, if you
are a physician's assistant,
to say, hey, doctor,
I think you missed
something, that is insane.
You could get fired for
that very easily, at least
in the US.
The way that the
hierarchy works,
it just doesn't allow
for that sort of thing.
So an interesting thing
that they discovered,
though, is there's this quirk in
the way doctors present highly
difficult cases, which
is a conference board.
So doctors get together
and they basically
go over their toughest cases
and they ask other doctors
for advice about how to do that.
And what they realized
is the person that
is the most overlooked there,
that has the most power there,
is the person that puts together
the slides for the doctors.
It's the person who
nobody appreciates
that has to get all this
data and put it on a slide
that doctors then
all have to look at.
They're all looking at
the same information.
And what they realized
is we can slip in some AI
into a PowerPoint program.
You might have thought that like
there was some great solution
having to do with some
great interface in the OR
about making decisions
about whether or not
you should implant a heart, but
instead they went to PowerPoint
and they said, like, we
can slip in this completely
non-threatening graph,
that some nurse can just
say like, oh, this is just
what the machine spat out.
I'm not taking you on.
I'm not trying to
question your expertise.
This is just what it did.
So as this team is
actually going forward,
the interesting thing
is they're discovering
different strategies.
Their next phase
of work is actually
having to do with trying
to almost trick doctors
into thinking that the
recommendations of the machine
are their own.
So in this case,
you would actually
have a Potemkin AI model in
which the doctor supposedly
trains the AI about what
the right recommendation is.
But it's not really training it.
I mean, a doctor is going
to give it a couple hundred
data points,
whereas this machine
can take in 35,000 from
incredibly difficult cases.
So it's really like--
what you're actually talking
about is the Ikea effect.
If you don't know,
this guy before
was Richard Thaler, the
famous behavioral economist.
This is not-- the research--
I'm adding a little bit
of interpretation here.
But what the researchers
are discovering,
this is the Ikea effect.
For those of you
who don't know, this
is a study done by
behavioral economists that
show that human beings, when
asked to co-craft something,
value it more.
So this study showed
that, basically,
after assembling an
Ikea chair, people
valued it economically
higher than from before,
or another chair that
somebody else had made.
So these are instances
where again, going back
to the introduction
to my talk, these
are situations where the
biases, the psychological quirks
of our minds, are actually the
fodder for design and design
thinking.
And so in this case, you
might think co-creation,
understanding
context, deference,
example-based learning, these
are just some of the quirks
about psychology,
about how we learn.
But if you might
have noticed, these
are the ways humans have
always used to build trust.
These are the ways
that you've always--
if you think about how
you get to know somebody
and how you actually create
a relationship with them,
you do something together.
You have this trade-off
of information.
You have the shared space
of understanding, right?
And the point that I want
to leave you guys with
is that we'll get
to the next phase
by watching people in new ways.
Too often I think UX research
is focused on end users
actually using a baked
product, whereas where
I think we're going is
finding new ways to look
at analogies that
we can learn from,
instructive ways in which the
ways people talk to each other,
the way they structure
their social interaction
can then change the
way we design products.
And interestingly enough,
Microsoft got to the same point
with their own AI
principles, which
closely mirror the principles
that I laid out before.
But the way they got there was
not by some interaction design
framework they dug
out from some paper,
like presented at
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
The way they got there was
watching actual real assistants
and how they developed
a relationship
with their clients.
Real personal assistants,
how they developed
trust over time
with their clients.
And what they did is try
to abstract the principles
for how personal assistants
with low capability
up front try to garner
trust over time.
So the point is, we're
no longer watching
the basic of
information processes,
and how human minds
process information and all
those things that got
remapped to things
like models and the
consistency in interfaces.
Rather, the structure
of our relationships
is now the fodder of design.
And this is what we need
to be understanding,
and this is what we
need to be watching,
is interaction designers,
is UX designers,
is engineers thinking about
how do you trust a system.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: We've got time for a
couple of questions for Cliff.
One over there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a PhD student that,
in a previous life,
I worked at a cancer hospital.
And I was just
wondering, when you're
talking about decision
assistance systems failing,
are you considering external
ones or like in-house ones?
Because we had quite
a successful one.
And I think part-- the
problem isn't just that they
don't trust it,
it's that it doesn't
do what they need it to do.
CLIFF KUANG: Yeah I think
that, actually, the greater
problem in a lot of the
peer-reviewed literature
has to do more with the fact
that a lot of times when
somebody comes in
outside to build
a system for other people,
they don't have UX people
at the fore.
They don't have any sort of
user research at the fore.
Typically, I mean, the sad
thing is with medical systems is
that it's a little bit
of a backwater in terms
of current thinking about
how to build software, right?
And that's really
the point there,
is that very rarely
do you assemble
the right people to identify
what the real problem is
and what the actual
context for use is.
So things that we take it for
granted in software development
today actually don't happen in
a lot of parts of the world.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So if we research people
and their relationships,
are we limiting ourselves
to just what we know today
in human forms?
So can we-- are there--
I mean, it's a bit rhetorical,
but are there things to learn
from human-robot relationships,
because we're going to find new
ways--
CLIFF KUANG: I would say as
fast as things are speeding
up right now, we
have a couple hundred
million years of evolution to
catch up on that has actually
done a very good job and a very
difficult job of figuring out
how our brains, which run
at like, the wattage less
than a light bulb, can
actually take in all
of these complicated pieces
of information and signals
and actually structure them in
a way that doesn't offend you
and it doesn't offend me
and allows us to create
some common space where
we agree that we're
having a conversation,
we're following each other.
These are incredibly
difficult things
that I would argue we are so--
at least as
interaction designers,
at least as UX
designers-- we're well
behind the curve of
understanding what that is
and how that works.
AUDIENCE: Great talk.
I did UX design
for about 15 years,
and when you started
your talk, talking
about conversational
agents, bots,
my first reaction regularly
when I talked to people
who try to design those and user
tested them, most of them suck.
I mean, they're
really bad, yeah.
So I kind of feel
like part of our job
as UX designers might be to
say you're on a hype bandwagon
with trying to build a
bot for your product.
And then we have
to kind of educate
the company, the
product managers,
the technologist about how
hard it is to get that right
and that it might be a cheaper,
easier, better UX experience
to not go that way.
CLIFF KUANG: And that's why I
think that a lot of the bot--
that stuff has
gone away and it's
been replaced with these
hybrid interfaces that
are a little bit of UI
inside of a bot, right?
I also work as a UX and
a product consultant.
I was just on a project
where the team was
hellbent on suggesting a chat
bot as a universal interface,
and I just wanted to throw up.
Like I just could not
get my head around it,
and I was just like, this
is never going to work.
But the thing is,
people just have
to go through this
learning curve, right?
We're going through-- and it's
a real disservice right now,
that I think a lot of the
tech companies are actually
pushing--
they're actually
part of the problem
in thinking that these
solutions-- and here, you
know, I would not
necessarily exempt,
like I know that I'm
here on Google's dime,
but I wouldn't exempt Google
from that either, right?
We're still struggling
with how you
create a mental model for what
something does when you have
no interface that's graphical.
And I don't know--
I don't think Google's
not alone in that.
I don't know what the
solution to that is.
We're still figuring it out.
It's going to take like
two decades of negotiation
about what machines do in
order for us to get that right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Oh, can you hear me?
Yeah.
Hi my name's Ilana.
I'm from the
DeepMind house team.
I was curious, do you
know what the team
motto was for the Watson team?
Did they involve UXR--
CLIFF KUANG: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --later on?
Just to test?
CLIFF KUANG: No, they involved
it upfront, very early.
But the point I
wanted to bring out
with that is there are blind
spots in the way we assume,
like--
there are just like-- there's
almost like, you know,
when the CIA actually
does analysis,
they actually have two teams
working in separate walls,
going at a problem,
hoping that they will
come to different solutions.
And the idea is that if they
converge, you've got something,
right?
That's how the
CIA does analysis.
I don't think right now,
UX doesn't do that, right?
You don't have adversarial
UX teams basically saying,
like, I'm going to fight you
about what the solution is
to this problem.
SPEAKER 2: You haven't
worked with us, so--
[LAUGHTER]
CLIFF KUANG: Fair
enough, fair enough.
But my point is,
in a lot of ways,
we don't know the assumptions
that we're making.
They assumed that
they were going
to build a pretty simple
database interface, right?
That's a perfectly
fine assumption, right?
That's a perfectly fine thing.
And you would have assumed
from user data, as a person,
like creating a monetizable
piece of software,
you would have thought the
more I can get somebody
to use this software,
the more valuable it is.
So those types of
assumptions, sometimes they
have to be thrown out.
And maybe it actually takes you
going all the way down the path
to actually realizing
that it didn't work,
but you have to be able
to throw something out
that you actually
committed to upfront.
SPEAKER 2: Got
time for one more.
AUDIENCE: Yeah I
have a question.
What would you think
about a Hippocratic oath
for developers?
Part of the reason that
people trust their doctors
is because they
really feel like they
have the best in mind for them.
I would say that that sort of
relationship with technologists
is becoming increasingly broken.
So would such an oath help?
CLIFF KUANG: I would agree,
and speaking in Europe,
obviously the amount of
skepticism about technology
is, actually, you guys have been
much more aggressive about it
with things like the GDPR.
I would agree that there needs
to be a Hippocratic oath.
What I would say
as a provocation is
that what companies have been
relying on right now heretofore
is marketing and
public sentiment
to take the place of
a Hippocratic oath.
So how you actually
get a Hippocratic oath
to seem meaningful in the
wake of the way public tech
companies have been
handling their--
getting basically public
buy-in is a hard problem.
I have no idea how somebody
would trust a Hippocratic oath
coming from the same bodies
that are governing themselves,
right?
It's going to be really hard.
I don't know the mechanism
that you create for that.
I don't think it's a bad idea.
I just think that
there is context there
and there is a way that we got
to here that you can't just,
like, say that we're going
to do this Hippocratic oath
and then it's just
going to change things.
And I haven't seen anybody
make that case yet.
SPEAKER 2: While
we're just do a check,
I'm going to [INAUDIBLE]
the privilege
a position of
having a microphone
and ask a question myself.
I Could you speak a little bit--
I think one of the
things that's implied
in some ways in
what you're saying
and the answer to the
last but one question
about often the
metrics that are used
by people who make decisions,
designers or otherwise, maybe
force some of the
design decisions.
Could you speak a
little bit-- you
talked about the sort
of change in perception
around design frameworks.
Have you thought at
all about metrics?
Daily active users,
monthly active users
is sort of the mantra,
particularly in the Valley
and amongst investors.
How do you think that
should change in this--
CLIFF KUANG: So I had this
evolving understanding.
I think that this is kind
of implied in the talk
that I gave, but I think
that we're moving up--
if you think about
Maslow's hierarchy,
where we're fulfilling
basic needs and where--
you think about interaction
design in its early phases,
having fulfilled basic
ideas and basic needs,
those things were relatively
easy to measure, right?
Were you able to
do what you want?
As UX designers,
we figured out how
to measure that pretty well.
But I think that
interfaces are now
moving higher up
Maslow's hierarchy
in the sense that they're
now faced with problems
like how do you trust something?
Did I find this satisfying?
Did this make me happier?
Those are things that we
don't have metrics yet.
But I would say to
you that right now, we
don't have a way to
actually-- for people
to actually express that
information in the interfaces
that they deal with.
An example that I would
give you, for example,
is that when you walk into
a travel agent, a really
good travel agent, or almost
any expensive high-end service,
you can specify what kind of
experience you want to have.
You can say to a
travel agent, like, I
want a little bit of adventure.
Not too much, mostly I want to
hang out on the beach, right?
You can give that
kind of like heuristic
about what kind of
experience you want to have.
Right now as a user
of computer software,
you cannot do that at all.
I can't tell my phone, hey,
phone, I want to chill out
today, right?
Hey, phone, keep me
super plugged in,
because I've got a lot
of really intense stuff
and I want to make sure that
I don't miss anything, right?
We're not designing for any
of that opt-in behavior that
would give us that data
to be able to measure
any of those things.
And so what I want to
say is there is probably
a future for an interface that
is about expressing high level
human desire as almost the
guidelines that a machine
learning algorithm can fill in
by providing some sort of usage
pattern that fits with
the high level heuristics
that you've offered as a user.
And until we get
to that point, I'm
just not sure how we're going
to figure that stuff out,
but I hope we do.
SPEAKER 2: Thank you.
Thank you, Cliff.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: So I'm
going to welcome Sarah.
Sarah is-- Sarah Gold
is an expert in--